>> ENCOURAGING MEN TO TAKE A
STAND AGAINST SO-CALLED TOXIC
MASCULINITY TOXIC MASCULINITY.
IT'S BECAUSE THEY DON'T WANT TO
BE HELD ACCOUNTABILITY.
TOXIC MASCULINITY IS NOT ACTUAL
MASCULINITY.
>> TOXIC MASCULINITY IS TIED SO
CLOSELY TO MASCULINITY.
>> Laura: YOU HEAR THAT A LOT,
MEN SHOULD BE MANLY WITHOUT
BEING TOXIC, WHATEVER THAT
MEANS.
BOYS SHOULD SOFTEN THEIR EDGES
BEFORE THEY STEP OVER THE LINE
BECAUSE OF ALL THAT
TESTOSTERONE.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO HIGHLIGHT THE
MOMENTS WHEN MAN'S NATURAL
STRENGTH AND CHIVALRY AND
COURAGE SAVES LIVES.
TAKE THE HEROES FROM TWO RECENT
SHOOTINGS.
WHEN A GUNMAN OPENED FIRED AT A
UNC CHARLOTTE CAMPUS FOR TWO
DAYS AGO, 21-YEAR-OLD RILEY
HOWELL CHARGED AT HIM, WAS SHOT
POINT BLANK, BUT STILL KNOCKED
THE SHOOTER OFF HIS FEET.
THEN THERE IS 18-YEAR-OLD KENDRA
CASTILLO, HE LEFT FROM HIS DECK
TUESDAY AT A COLORADO STEM
SCHOOL WHEN A SHOOTER ENTERED
THE CLASSROOM.
WHILE HE CONFRONTED THE SUSPECT
WITH LITTLE REGARD FOR HIS OWN
LIFE, OTHERS RUSHED TO SAFETY.
KENDRICK, TRAGICALLY, WAS
KILLED.
BUT BECAUSE OF HIS BRAVERY,
WELL, SUMMING HIS FATHER
REMEMBERED ABOUT HIM.
>> IT'S NO SURPRISE THAT IF
DANGER WASN'T FACING HIM, HE
WOULD APPROACH IT.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD, I BAWLED
WHEN I SAW THAT TODAY.
WHAT POSSESSES MEN TO ASK THIS
WAY?
FOR ANSWERS, I WANT TO BRING IN
DR. DREW PINSKY.
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THESE ISSUES
BEFORE, BUT THESE TWO CASES, I
HAVE A GOOSE BUMPS HEARING THE
DAD, HIS LOSS, HIS SADNESS.
BUT THE HEROISM AND THE
SACRIFICE FROM YOUNG MEN, 16,
17, 18 YEARS OF AGE, NOT HERE TO
SPEAK THEIR OWN STORY, THEIR OWN
TRUTH.
INCREDIBLE.
>> THERE IS A TENDENCY FOR THE
MALES TO TURN THEIR AGGRESSION,
WHICH IS WHAT PEOPLE WORRY ABOUT
WITH TOXIC MASCULINITY -- TURN
AGGRESSION INTO A POSITIVE
IMPULSE.
WHETHER THEY ARE LANDING AT THE
BEACH IN OMAHA OR RUSHING A
SHOOTER, THERE IS A NATURAL
TENDENCY THAT THEY ACTUALLY
LEARN THROUGH ROUGH-AND-TUMBLE
PLAY THAT IS AUTOMATIC AND YOUNG
MALES, WHERE THEY LEARN TO SORT
OF MODULATE THEIR AGGRESSION BUT
THEY ALSO LEARN HOW TO TURN IT
UP SO THEY KNOW WHEN IT'S TIME
TO BRING IT ON.
>> Laura: SO MUCH IN SOCIETY
TODAY DISCOURAGES MEN FROM
BELIEVING THERE IS A NATURAL
IMPULSE TO BE CHIVALROUS OR SHOW
THIS TYPE OF PHYSICAL COURAGE.
YOUR STEREOTYPING, THERE IS A
PUSH AND PULL TO THAT.
>> I ACTUALLY AGREE WITH YOU, IT
IS EXCLUSIVE.
ON "GAME OF THRONES" ," IT'S NOT
LIKE THE OTHER MALES ARE
EXCLUSIVELY HEROIC.
WOMEN CAN BE HEROIC, TOO, BUT
BECAUSE OF THE AGGRESSION AND
THE THINGS THAT MAKES US "TOXIC"
IT MAKES US DO THE THINGS THAT
PUSH SOCIETY FORWARD AND HELP
PEOPLE IN EXTREME SITUATIONS.
ULTIMATELY, IT'S AGGRESSION AND
WE ARE TURNING OUR AGGRESSION
INTO HELPFULNESS AND IT'S OKAY.
>> Laura: ANOTHER ISSUE WITH A
SUSPECT IN THE COLORADO SCHOOL
SHOOTING WHICH IS BEING
OVERLOOKED IN SOME QUARTERS.
IT WAS A TRANSGENDER MALE IN THE
PROCESS OF TRANSITIONING, FROM A
FEMALE BIOLOGICALLY MALE.
TAKING HORMONES AND SO FORTH,
WHAT WOULD THAT SERIES OF DRUGS
DO, OR HOW COULD IT AFFECT THE
MENTAL STATE OF AN INDIVIDUAL?
GIVEN HOW LITTLE WE HAVE AS FAR
AS INFORMATION ON THE WAY THESE
DRUGS AFFECT BEHAVIOR,
ESPECIALLY THE TESTOSTERONE.
>> THAT IS CORRECT.
WE HAVE VERY LIMITED RESEARCH ON
THE TOPIC AND I KNOW OF NO
EVIDENCE THAT IT TURNS PEOPLE
ACTUALLY VIOLENT.
BUT WHEN YOU EXPOSE PEOPLE TO
MALE LEVELS OF VIOLENCE, AND
I'VE TALKED TO MANY TRANSGENDER
FOLKS OVER THE YEARS AND I AM
INTERESTED IN TALKING TO THE
FEMALE TO MALE PATIENTS BECAUSE
THEY SAY THE SAME THING, I HAD
NO IDEA YOU WERE DEALING WITH
THIS.
AND I POINT OUT TO THEM, NOT
ONLY HAVE WE BEEN DEALING WITH
THIS CHEMICALLY IN OUR SYSTEM,
GOD SAW FIT TO GIVE THIS TO US
AT 13.
>> Laura: I WANT TO READ THIS,
THIS IS FROM DR. PAUL, AND THEY
SAID THIS THERAPY MAY HAVE REAL
LONG-TERM EFFECTS ON CHILDREN'S
PHYSICAL AND PSYCHOLOGICAL
DEVELOPMENT, WHETHER BLOCKING
PUBERTY IS THE BEST WAY TO TREAT
GENDER DYSPHORIA IT REMAINS FAR
FROM SETTLED AND IT SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED A DRASTIC AND
EXPERIMENTAL MEASURE.
JOHNS HOPKINS, THE PREMIER
RESEARCHERS ARE ON THIS.
OTHERS WHO USE THESE DRUGS SAY
THE SAME THING.
HEY, WE DON'T HAVE PEER-REVIEWED
STUDIES YET PARENTS ARE GIVING
KIDS OF THESE DRUGS BEFORE THE
AGE OF 18, BEFORE THEY CAN GIVE
REAL CONSENT EVEN.
>> WE DON'T HAVE THE RESEARCH.
YOU'VE DECIDED, THAT IS CLEAR,
THAT IS TRUE.
FOR ME TO SAY SOMETHING
CONCLUSIVE ABOUT AGGRESSION AND
VIOLENCE, I CAN'T DO IT.
BUT TESTOSTERONE IS THE DRUG OF
AGGRESSION.
LET ME TELL YOU ONE QUICK THING
THAT BOTHERS ME, WE'VE GOTTEN TO
A POSITION IN THIS COUNTRY WHERE
WE PRIVILEGE PSYCHIATRIC
SYMPTOMS OVER THE WELL-BEING OF
THE INDIVIDUAL AND THE
COMMUNITY.
IF THIS KID WAS HAVING A LOT OF
SYMPTOMATOLOGY, NO ONE WAS
ALLOWED TO DO ANYTHING IF THE
KID DIDN'T WANT ANYTHING DONE,
UNLESS THE PARENTS DEMANDED A
PAIRED WITH THE 18 YEARS OLD,
YOU CAN'T DO ANYTHING.
THERE IS PRIVILEGE IN THE LAW
FOR PSYCHIATRIC SYMPTOMS, THAT